obviously NGO is successful if you look
at this room look at what's going on
here yeah and a lot of people have asked
why NGO is successful or ask me why NGO
is successful and a lot of people have
answers that involve tooling or the
language or things about it
but I think those are all sort of
superficial reasons I think the real
reason is simplicity NGO is simple at
least compared to a lot of other
languages that are running around at the
moment
and so but simplicity is actually a
complicated subject and there are many
ways to think about it last year about
May I think I went to a conference
hosted by Microsoft called lion got
mixed and I saw a number of actually
quite interesting talks many of which
were the leaders of a particular
language talking about a new version
that was coming out like JavaScript PHP
C sharp and so on and I really was
struck by one thing about these talks
and these languages which is most of the
talks consisted of features being added
by taking something from another
language and adding it to this one so
you know Java scripts getting classes
and that kind of thing and I realized
that what's happening is all of these
languages are turning into the same
language there's a concept called
language relativity in linguistics which
is also colloquially called the
sapir-whorf hypothesis although neither
sup here nor Worf quite agreed with it
and the idea is basically that language
influences thought and the sort of
cartoon version is you know if you speak
French your your your more amorous and
it's pretty obviously controversial
there's some evidence that there may be
some truth but not very much but I think
it's really obvious if you think about
it that computer languages this very
much applies if you're in a logic
programming language you write a very
different kind of program you think a
different way than if you're using an
object-oriented programming language or
a concurrent one it's very much like
disciplines in mathematics you don't
solve calculus using linear algebra even
though they have some structural
comparisons and so I'm worried about
this trend in the languages because they
all converge to the same language we're
all going to be thinking the same way
and that would make life very very
uninteresting you want to have different
languages for different problems you
want to have different domains we solve
by different ways of
thinking and different notations in
other words you kind of want a tool
that's optimized for each particular way
you're working now these tiles that line
next we're about things like Java eight
equi script six which has been a long
time coming
c-sharp C+ was 14 and the few others
that didn't quite fit this mold but
let's just talk about the ones that do
as I said these languages are evolving
by adding features that means they're
becoming more complicated their
complexity is growing while they are
simultaneously becoming more similar to
one another that's a very strange
situation for a field to begin I would
summarize that is bloat without
distinction go however as I hope you
appreciate isn't like that goes a
different language in this respect it
doesn't try to be like these other
languages because it's not taking
features it doesn't try to compete by
saying oh if they have that feature we
better have it or people will be
unwilling to use their language in fact
as of goal one which is what three years
old now the language is fixed you know
you may have noticed that the features
that have gone in since then are
absolutely tiny there's really been no
significant change to the language since
it's go one and that was the point of go
one however many newcomers to go start
by asking can we add this feature of the
language can we make air handling
different can we change the way arrays
work or something like that but the
language is fixed those things don't get
to go in but it's not just that the
language is fixed it's because adding
features will not really make go better
and why is that true it would just make
it bigger but it would make it less
different and both of those are worse in
my opinion but obviously you need
features you can't have a programming
language without some features in it but
which ones
well obviously the right ones and so we
picked the right ones how did we pick
the right ones well one way is that the
original language was designed by Ken
Thompson Robert Greer and myself and we
all have very different backgrounds Ken
and I had worked together at Bell Labs
quite a bit but we also had done very
different things and you know ken is a
God so when we came to talk about what
was going into the language we insisted
that all three of us not only agreed
with the feature going in but agreed
that it was the right feature to go in
and with our different backgrounds and
different perspectives that dramatically
narrowed the number of things that went
into go but you still have to pick what
to put in and our overriding thing for
doing this was readability and here's
how we think about this if a language
has too many features or even more than
you know you might need you've spent
time programming thinking about which
features to use if there's really a lot
of features you may look at the line of
code write it one way oh I could do
something different I could use this
feature I use that feature you might
even spend you know half an hour playing
with a few lines of code to find all the
right ways you could use different
features to make the code work a certain
way and it's kind of a waste of time to
do that but worse when you come back to
the program later you have to recreate
that thought process you not only have
to understand this complicated program
programming language doing whatever it's
doing you have to understand why the
programmer who might be you decided that
this was the way to approach the problem
from the feature set available and that
is just I think bad engineering the
summary summarization of this is the
code is harder to understand simply
because it is using a more complex
language you want to have just one way
or at least fewer simpler easier to
understand ways so in other words
features add complexity we want
simplicity features hurt readability we
really want readability and readability
is by my opinion the most important
feature of a programming language
because readable means reliable if you
can read the code and know what it means
then you can it's easier to understand
it's easier to work on it's easier to
extend it's easier to fix when it breaks
it's easier to understand why it's
broken these are all good things and
that is why readability is so important
if the language is complicated on the
other hand you have to understand more
to understand even where to start
working on the program and you have to
understand a more complicated model in
which the program is being written these
cost time and make the language harder
to use but there's a trade-off obviously
making more features in a language gives
you more fun things to play with and so
there's a fundamental trade-off ingo
that was made in a different direction
from most other languages and the
trade-off is what do you want a language
is more fun to write in
or easier to work on and maintain and
for the most part the decisions in go
about what went in were about long-term
maintenance and in particularly in the
context of large-scale programming
although that's a little off the topic
today no the thing is you put features
in to make languages expressive you
obviously want to not have to type you
know hexadecimal numbers which would be
a very low feature way to write code but
obviously very hard to use you just be
careful because you make something too
concise it can become just unreadable
this example here is a real working
program in a dialect of APL called
dialogue and an implements Conway's Game
of Life and I think you could argue even
if you're an expert APL programmer it's
not very readable APL is famous for
being easy to write and hard to read but
and I think it's very we have to be very
careful we don't write software like
this in the modern distributed multi
programmer you know open source world
but there's a more important point I
think well maybe maybe an equally
important point which is when you have
features that add expressiveness they
typically add expense for instance a lot
of people have asked for things like map
and filter to be built in to go and we
said no one of the reasons we said no is
that if you if you have things like map
and filter they're going to use them
that's why they're there but they may be
more expensive than a simple for loop
and when the features are there to make
life easier and more expressive they
tend to generate more expensive in terms
of computer time solutions to problems
that have much simpler solutions so
they're also they may help the
programmer although not always but
they'll almost always hurt the computer
unless the implementation is extremely
smart and believe me the implementation
of APL is extremely smart so that
actually is a modestly efficient
implementation of the game of life but
you wouldn't you could do much much
better if you wrote a simpler program
but you gotta be careful because if you
make everything too expansive and
explain everything in detail you get a
very verbose language I won't name any
but you know the ones I'm thinking of
where it just seems like you're writing
too much to say a simple thing so you
have to balance this no so what we did
was we tried to make the right selection
building on the ideas that we're
familiar so that a programmer with a
background in procedural programming
like with C or Java or even you know
Fortran say could read a go program and
get a pretty good idea right out of the
box what was happening and not be
confused by strange notation so you have
to balance you have to be concise but be
expressive make sure that the program is
easy to read you have to pick the right
fit set of features in other words not
just features for features sake way I
like to think of this is to think of the
entire world of programming is a vector
space of very high dimension and what
you want to do is to find the basis set
that covers that vector space so that
you can write the program's you want by
combining the appropriate orthogonal
because that's what basis that is
orthogonal set of features and what
happens when you add features for
expressiveness or for fun is it tends to
add more non basis vectors into that
space and so there become many paths to
get to a particular solution so that's
when we say features are orthogonal
that's what we mean we mean that they
cover this space but we also mean they
interact really well so if you take
feature a and feature B and you write a
program that uses them they work exactly
the way you expect feature a and feature
B to work they're not as some weird
diagonal that causes all kinds of
complications you have to worry about
again I won't mention which language I'm
thinking of so you have to keep all of
this in mind when you're designing a
language and also think about what the
goal is what are you actually trying to
achieve what is the problem domain that
this language is being done for well in
gos case we were trying to write code
for Google because that's what we do and
go is software that at least the parts
that we work on are mostly
infrastructure server infrastructure
what we now call cloud software but used
to just be called servers and to do this
you have to find enough pieces to build
the software and so the fundamental
components we started with were ideas
like concrete data types you know
integers structures floating-point
numbers
functions and methods interfaces
packages concurrency and then the sort
of guiding engineering principle of
having a really good fast implementation
with the ability to have a really good
tooling and with that's sort of all with
all those guidelines which is a fairly
complicated set of considerations the
fesus sort of fell into place and
actually ended up being kind of simple
in practice and in fact simplicity can
be expressive
this is a very simple drawing when Rene
drew this a while back and yeah he's
expressive right he's not really a gofer
and I'm not talking about the Magritte
version of Sistina buzzing gopher I mean
he's just the representation of a gopher
very much like like shreves talked
earlier with the horse right and so this
for me is what is part of like the ethos
of go here's this really simple drawing
that represents what Gogh is like we can
put more features don't we make it more
like a gopher we could give them lots
more detail and we get something like
this right but mostly what we've added
is ugliness and hair we haven't actually
made embedded right its complexity
without clarity so but I want to make a
really important point here which is
I've said go as simple but it's not it's
very complicated I know I worked on it
it's one of those complicated things
they've ever worked on and yet it feels
simple and I think that's a really
important idea and it feels simple
because these pieces fit together
orthogonal and that requires a lot of
design a lot of thinking a lot of
refinement and implementation and
re-implementation and to put a very
bluntly simplicity at least in this
context is the art of hiding complexity
so let me talk about a few simple things
and go and why they're really
complicated garbage collection
goroutines constants interface and
packages each of these things is very
simple and very complicated but at the
same time there's a lot of other
subjects I could pick but let's quickly
go through these garbage collection is
probably the best example of simplicity
hiding complexity
what is the programmer interface for
garbage collection
there isn't one can't get simpler than
that the empty set is as simple as it
gets
right and yet look how hard it is to
implement all that incredible code to
deal with stack maps and you know the
copying the stacks on when you need to
grow them and tracking all the
references down pausing it running in
parallel with the with the mutator it's
a tremendously complicated problem that
fortunately I didn't have to work on we
have some really good people in the go
team who did but I think it's amazing to
consider how much code is there for
something that has absolutely no user
interface there isn't even a free
function in go there's nothing but
garbage collection
memory and it's remarkable to point out
that it isn't even in the spec the goal
language does not define that it is
garbage collected in the specification
the only mention is in the introduction
was a throw throw away property of a
feature of language that's how small and
therefore how simple the spec is I mean
that the garbage collection is and you
how complicated it is behind the scenes
and it also makes code simpler because
you don't have to think about who owns
the data who's going to free it how to
manage it for you you can think about
implementation details and efficiency
but for just straightforward go
programming garbage collection hides
everything it's fantastic and one of the
things that people love about go is the
concurrency
I think it's arguably one of the
simplest concurrency models available in
a programming language not that they're
that many but there are some others
there's several components to it go
routines channels and select and I'm
gonna talk about go routines for a
minute you start a go routine with the
go keyword you say go space geo space
and then the function call so three
keystrokes you can't make it much
shorter than that yeah I can imagine
one or two changes I can take but three
keystrokes and you've just started a sub
process in the general mathematical term
and so it's like garbage collection
because it's extremely simple UI there's
nothing in the UI about the size of the
stack or a thread ID or managing
goroutines show them down things like
that there's there's no completion
status there's no type a lot of people
ask for these things that in fact some
other languages or thread packages
provide the equivalent functionality of
some of those things but we didn't put
them in we wanted to go key word to be
so simple that had the minimum possible
UI here's a function call run it
alongside my other things three
keystrokes and that's part of this
minimal design and then Crossley's
talked earlier today he talked about one
of the reasons I think you can
appreciate now why Frances are no ID on
a goroutine internally of course you
have a lot of complexity managing this
managing the relationship between the
goroutine implementation the runtime
stack and the garbage collector for
example credibly complicated behind the
scenes stuff but three keystrokes
constant
this is one of my favorite things about
NGO that most people don't even think
about and they don't think about it
because it's incredibly simple when we
decided that go ahead to be strictly
typed that meant that numeric types
could not be interchange freely that was
a very common source of bugs in C and
C++ you were not allowed and go to take
an int and put it into a float 64 or
anything like that but that can be very
clumsy you don't want have to say float
64 zero every time you want to use a
floating point zero so we had this idea
which is one of those I think relatively
novel ideas which is that we made
constant just be numbers they're just
numbers even though the language is
strictly typed and this means you get to
throw around things like 1e9 dividing
into a time dot second which has a
strict type and to get this to work was
really art is one of the hardest things
in designing language not in
implementing it so much but designing it
we had to worry about what infinite
presented and precision
integers means what infinite precision
floating point means what happens to the
promotion rules if you divide an integer
two versus divide a floating point 2 and
you get corner cases like this crazy
shift which I can't run but what do you
think the answer is to this what does
this program print it's got a 2.0 and a
2.0 shift is zero and asking the type of
both of them you have to think don't you
this is a place where the complexity
comes up you get an you actually get a
float 64 in an INT and that's not a good
thing it's just a consequence of the
rules that we've eventually converged on
to make constants work right but for the
most part you never see these kind of
words when you're using constants they
just feel like numbers and it's
fantastic so I'm not totally satisfied
but I think it was a really good example
again of simplicity hiding complexity
and I wrote a blog post called on blog
that golang.org slash constants that
talks about this stuff and much more
detail interfaces one of those favorite
features for myself and I think for a
lot of programmers a very simple idea
all there is is a set of methods people
ask for data as well all the time not
going to get it it's just it's just
functions very simple you also need a
variable of type interface you can
program with these things but even here
you get some funny
things happening because you for
instance can assign OS dusted into a
reader no problem
you can assign OS dusted into an empty
interface no problem but if you have to
narrow the interface you have to do a
dynamic type check which we call the
type assertion and one of the things
that's not well-known about go is that
was not in the original design we
realized a few months into it that we
needed type assertions to make the
program work right the addition of
effectively dynamic typing into a
statically programmed language was a
complicated thing that we had to deal
with and make it work and it's I'm not
totally thrilled with how it worked out
but I think it's pretty good and it does
in the end do its job but for the most
part what you have again is a very
simple idea an interface is a set of
methods and with again a quite
complicated set of rules behind them
that mostly just do what you want but it
was hard in fact interfaces are probably
goes most distinctive and powerful
feature I think concurrency is talked
about a little more but you don't write
as much concurrency in a typical program
as using your faces interfaces have a
profound effect on the library they've
enabled the very structure of go
programs to be the way they are with a I
think the most component oriented
architecture of any programming language
I've used and so they in fact I think
can safely say they are simple to use
even though they add complexity they're
worth it and finally packages packages
are one of the hardest things we had to
deal with in design the language it
doesn't seem like there's anything there
what do you have you have packaged big
there's the name of the package you have
import stringing the client we're gonna
what's there it took us months to figure
this out because it interacts with
things like scoping naming information
hiding isolation linking compiling cross
compiling and getting all those details
right took a very very long time and but
on the other hand you guys never think
about this stuff right they just work
somebody earlier today said import was
this favorite keyword that's great I
love it
and all that complexity which is
fantastically intricate when you start
talking about working across multiple
language implementations of you know
four different architectures and
different operating system
it's all hidden behind this simple
package idea that has basically two
concepts and that includes things like
GoGet which is a fantastic enabler for
open-source based on the fact that the
import string is literally that a string
with no semantic meaning within the
language so again very hard to implement
very complicated under the covers
extremely simple to use and I think
after garbage collection packages are
actually the most the best example of
simplicity hiding complexity let me show
you here's a simple example it's just
the sort of standard hello world server
it's written with some Japanese in it
because why not but you I think and
recognized as competent go programmers
very quickly what that program does I
don't need to run it it does run it does
what you think very simple right it's
hardly anything they're just a few lines
of code starts a server runs it okay
here's what's going on inside this
program first of all most visibly it's
doing unicode utf-8 working flawlessly
it seems porting some magic packages and
they're being used from flog net HTTP
HTTP being one of the most awesome
packages there's an F printf directly to
a network connection which is
interesting and unusual there's a
function being promoted to a method that
with the handle func in there which is a
bit of a mind blow to people knew to go
was mind-blowing to me when it was
pointed out to me about rust that we
could do that it's also truly concurrent
this server won't block as long as
there's enough resources on the server
hardware you can have zillions of people
talking to this service simultaneously
which is to say it's production ready
there it is a production ready web
server in just a few lines of code it
doesn't get much simpler than that right
so in summary simplicity is complicated
but the clarity is worth the fight
I don't want to hang out with the gopher
on the right I want to hang out with the
guy in the left he's much more
expressive and fun and much less hairy
so in conclusion simplicity is very hard
to design it's very complicated to build
it sounds strange to say that but it's
true making things simple is hard work
but if you get it right
you get something that's very easy to
use and I think the success of go and
the fact that you're all here listening
to me
proves that there's something there
thank you
[Applause]